par plus nous nous interrogerons aussi
sur les pistes les hypothèses
privilégiées mais d'abord un mot sur la
cible des terroristes
elle n'a pas été choisi au hasard on
l'évoquait il y a un instant marrakech
est la capitale du tourisme et en
particulier du tourisme français nicolas
chateauneuf marrakech c'est le symbole
du tourisme au maroc
chaque année la place jamâa el fna les
échoppes du souk
le minaret de la koutoubia attire un
million six cent mille touristes et
parmi eux huit cent mille français soit
la moitié
marrakech compte un million d'habitants
ce qui en fait la quatrième ville du
pays alors que casablanca concentrent
les activités économiques
rabat les administrations marrakech est
la principale destination touristique au
maroc et l'industrie du tourisme cela
représente 8 % de l'économie marocaine
marrakech concentre aussi une importante
communauté de résidents français qui
vivent à l'année leur nombre est estimé
à 11 milles mais la ville compte
dix-huit mille propriétaires français un
chiffre qui traduit le pouvoir
d'attraction qu'exerce marrakech sur les
ressortissants de l'hexagone